Ça c'est boulanger. On y renvoi,
Paul Caplette producteurs de blé
à Saintonjour.
- Bonjour.
- Qu'est-ce que ça change le
contexte mondial : le prix du
blé à cause de l'embargo russe,
est-ce que ça chanarché à vous?
- Sûrement. Quand on parle
d'avant décembre, on a signé des
contrats pour du blé5 dollars ls
fermer et présentement si je
vaudrait entre 550 dollars la
tonne. Ça a pratiquement doublé.
Les prix qu'on a fait ce sont ft
alléchant ce qui veut dire que
moi comme agriculteur cette
année, par rapport à ce prix de
blé est vendu par ce fournisseur
qui vend la farine au boulanger,
de suite. Il y en aura mais pour
l'an prochain.
Pour cette année ce sera la même
chose.
- C'est important ce que vous
expliquez parce que vous avez
des cont Même si  Même si  Mêmel
monte, ce n'est pas comme
l'essence, vous ne pouvez pae la
saison avance6
- une fois que le contrat est la
parce que le client avec qui
fait en fait, sa procédure, sa
presse des améliorations a fait
mais les contrats sont faites
prix ferme à l'année d'avant le
blé de livet. Les contrats s
tous signés avant la hausse.
insignifiant mais le même
d'aujourd'hui qui sera en vente
aurait une hausse qui
s'annoncerait autour de 550.
- Non, exemple et contrôle qu'oà
cette définition la. Ça fa
peu comique, mais je vaiscapabln
marché pour les poulets et les
100 dollj'ai 22 cennes.
Cher le blé j'ai 22 scènes ma
partie comme agriculteur ça
aurait représenté...
ont y>gné de9Orat9
prix et du blé mondial... vous
ne faites pas la passe?
- C'est ce que son portefeuille
diversifnada,
c'est peut-être pas tout fait
d'avance, mais la partie qui est
faite es des
prix fermés au moment... en
pain, la partie qui vous revient
ntre qui coûtequatre dollars eti
je l'avais consulté à l'époque.
Ça représente pas mal ce qui se
passe da
passent de la ferme et qui
chemine vers les transformat
de farine, Boulangerie, et après
on s'occupe de la distributiet .
évidence?se
refléter encore plus l'an
prochain parce que si le système
continu comme ça, c'est sûrnontx
n'avons pas le choix de cette
réajusté
agriculteurs vont dire : on va's
si c'est pas corrigé. Pour
du pain onter,me agriculteur, ct
pas moi comme agriculteur qui et
cas pour ceux qui ont fait des
s
panneaux qui en profitent en ce
moment. pourrait arriver
quand tous les
contrats seront négociés. À
voir. Parlez-nous du temps, on
voit la lumière q
deux articles sur la sécheresse,
quel est l'état de la situation
et que d- On n'en a eu deux dans
deux der
historique. L'an passé on s'en
belle pluie lundi qui a corrigét
correcte. Les nouvelles cultures
,
mais avec la pluie qu'on a eue,p
à la conservation et protectione
pour avoir des couverts végétaux
qui sont
sur le sol qui fait que le
soleil moins directement et on
est capable de garder plus n
pas la perdre en évaporation. Ça
nous aide beaucoup et c'est ce
qui nous a aidé be de l'air sece
rosée on a quand même eu un bel
hiver en neige... c'est comme se
crédit toujours sur la limite
de défoncer. Il va falloir gérer
notre eau et rester aux aguets.e
qu'on a eue et ce qui annonce
vendredi, ça va nous donneru ga.
(rire)terme.
- Vous avez dit le bon terme. On
va faire le point